j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
consacré au plan d'action présenté le 5
janvier dernier par le ministre de la
Justice budget en haut s'embauche de
magistrat création de nouvelles places
de prison simplification du code de
procédure pénale Eric Dupond-Moretti
annoncé une soixantaine de mesures
plutôt bien accueillis au tribunal de
Saint-Quentin dans l'Aisne où s'est
rendu Cécile Sioux ce qu'on a reçu la
procédure pour la présentation de tout à
l'heure cédric longelein est procureur
ce jour-là il fait le point avec sa
greffière pour savoir si ses collègues
avocat et magistrats ont bien reçu un
dossier de comparution immédiate
également à la présidente d'audience
d'accord très bien donc il arrive dans
combien de temps d'ici une heure à peu
près
une procédure d'urgence désormais
entièrement numérisée qui permet aux
personnel de justice de ne plus obtenir
les dossiers à la dernière minute comme
c'était le cas avant qu'un seul dossier
papier et que 5 personnes doivent le
consulter
il faut attendre que son prédécesseur
est plus consulter le dossier ou il faut
faire des copies donc ce qui entraînait
deux voire trois copies d'une même
procédure là où maintenant tout le monde
a le dossier avant même que la personne
soit arrivée dans dans sur le sur le
site judiciaire le tribunal de
Saint-Quentin dans l'Aisne a adopter la
marche vers la numérisation depuis 8 ans
en avant si le test depuis un an la
signature numérique donc la signature
électronique ça prend cette forme donc
c'est une Marianne avec la date et ça
vous évite d'avoir
en fait à imprimer un document le signer
manuscritement puis le scanner
pour l'envoyer à votre destinataire ça
permet également quand vous êtes de
permanence le week-end et bien de ne pas
avoir à revenir au tribunal vous pouvez
de chez vous simplicité rapidité grâce à
ses outils tout le monde y gagne au
palais de justice de Saint-Quentin pour
Cédric logelin il faut aller plus loin
le procureur espère que la
transformation numérique annoncée par le
garde des sceaux dans son plan justice
poussera encore plus le recours au
digital je suis une très bonne chose ce
que ça permet de moderniser la justice
qui parfois est vue comme institution
vieillissante et de pousser la
modernisation et puis aussi de permettre
aux justiciables c'est encore un des
projets qu'on a à Saint-Quentin et bien
de pouvoir suivre l'évolution de son
dossier sur internet ou sur un
smartphone pour ne pas avoir à se
déplacer au tribunal je pense à des
justiciers qui ont des difficultés de
locomotion qui ont pas les moyens
d'avoir tout simplement une voiture mais
ils pourront consulter depuis chez eux
l'état d'avancement de leur dossier la
toute nouvelle présidente du tribunal
Rose-Marie un a-t-on également beaucoup
des annonces du ministre et notamment
les ouvertures de poste car sa
juridiction fonctionne en ce moment en
sous-effectif 15 greffiers sont présents
au lieu de 19 et pendant quatre mois il
a manqué deux magistrats à l'appel sur
les 10 normalement présents ça signifie
qu'à 8 ils ont dû pendant 4 mois faire
le travail de 10 personnes
habituellement forcément si vous êtes
huit magistrats pour faire le travail de
10 forcément vous n'allez pas réussir à
faire exactement la même chose que les
10 magistrats qui auraient été présents
et puis ensuite ils sont amenés à
prioriser des affaires et donc certaines
vont forcément attendre plus longtemps
pour être traité un ralentissement des
procédures mais surtout une situation
pesante pour le personnel les
conséquences
sont le fait que il y a une surcharge de
travail
des fonctionnaires de fait des heures
supplémentaires qui sont générés une
fatigue décharger le personnel grâce à
de nouveaux effectifs rosemar et uno a
tendance à voir plus sur les annonces du
ministre elle ne s'est pas encore si son
tribunal pourra bénéficier de moyens
supplémentaires je vous présente tout de
suite les invités de notre second débat
Agnès canalière bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes c'est un triste LR de la
Seine-Maritime et membre de la
commission des Lois du Sénat Erwan
baladant bonsoir bonsoir venu député
MoDem du Finistère vice-président de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
Jérôme posa bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi magistrat vice-président au
tribunal de Nancy en charge de
l'application des peines président de
l'association amour de la justice qui
regroupe magistrat personnel et
usagés et puis auteur de ce manifeste
pour une justice humaine et indépendante
programme de refonte de la justice
coécrit avec Marie bougnou et Laurent ce
bac aux éditions Enrique B Matthieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés peut-être pour commencer votre
avis un peu général sur ce plan ces
annonces de d'Éric Dupond-Moretti Agnès
est-ce qu'il est aussi ambitieux ce plan
que la firme le garde des sceaux
écoutez effectivement il prend les
conclusions de ce qui est sorti lors des
états généraux de la justice qui était
une vision à 360 degrés des difficultés
que rencontre la justice aujourd'hui et
des besoins de réforme c'est vrai que
c'est 60 propositions et de son ta
catalogue à peu près complet même s'il y
a quelques petits trous dans la raquette
mais c'est plutôt relativement complet
la vraie question qui se pose
aujourd'hui ça va être la mise en œuvre
de ces réformes notamment
l'enchevêtement des unes par rapport aux
autres parce qu'il y a des attentes
majeures par une justice aujourd'hui qui
est malade c'est à dire quand vous avez
entendu une sorte de calendrier ou de
priorisation en quelque sorte l'enjeu
est avant tout c'est celui effectivement
de la priorisation et par quoi
commence-t-on c'est une question qu'on
pose régulièrement aux gardes des sourds
on n'a pas aujourd'hui les vrais
réponses parce qu'il me semble que dans
ce sujet là eu égard à la situation de
la justice aujourd'hui en France du
mal-être de nombreux magistrats
personnels de justice greffiers il
faudra non pas ajouter de la réforme à
la réforme parce que aujourd'hui ils
disent de sans pouvoir et ne plus
réussir à absorber toutes ces nouvelles
réformes qui bouleverse leur quotidien
mais qu'il faut bien avant tout se
stabiliser les moyens des outils avant
d'introduire des nouvelles réformes
alors la question des moyens ça nous
ramène au budget donc là il y a une
forme de continuité avec le premier
quinquennat et les premières
augmentations de budgétaire obtenu par
par Monsieur Dupont-Moretti s'il y avait
une première urgence c'était l'urgence
budgétaire et de moyens injustices on
avait un ancien garde des sceaux qui
parlait de clochardisation de la justice
vous souvenez de ça et quand on est
justiciable on se rendait compte aussi
de la lenteur des difficultés voilà bon
les moyens on les a mis on continuera à
les mettre sur 10 ans sur les deux
mandats les deux mandats du Président
Macron et donc les deux législatures ça
va être presque 60% d'augmentation du
budget de la justice c'est pas rien mais
une fois qu'on a parlé et je vous
rejoins en partie une fois qu'on a parlé
des du budget il faut parler de
réorganisation
de moyens qui sont affectés au bon
endroit et tout ça c'était c'était ce
que moi je salue dans le travail des
états généraux de la justice c'est que
c'était un vrai travail autant des
professionnels de tous les
professionnels de la justice mais aussi
des citoyens français qui ont été un
jour ou l'autre confrontés à la justice
et ces états généraux de la justice et
le président sauvé ils ont fait un
travail remarquable je trouve de
priorisation et là maintenant le garde
des sceaux les apprises à son compte et
c'est normal il va falloir que ça se
décline et nous les législateurs il va
falloir qu'on soit à l'écoute maintenant
des des juridictions pour faire la fin
du bon travail qui est commencé je
trouve alors vous avez vous qui ce
chiffre on va écouter première réaction
on va s'appuyer comme ça sur certaines
des annonces de d'Éric Dupond-Moretti
donc 5 janvier dernier sur la question
budgétaire écoutez
le budget continuera d'augmenter jusqu'à
atteindre près de 11 milliards d'euros
en 2027 ainsi à l'issue des deux
quinquennats le budget de la justice
aura connu une hausse de près de 60%
Jérôme est-ce que ça suffit c'est est-ce
que on parlait de on partait de
tellement loin que que ces sommes
suffisent ce qu'on rattrape notre retard
alors on a parlé de budget historique
moi je contextualise et je vais nuancer
je parle de budget de rattrapage
historique on parle de tellement loin
comme vous dites que effectivement ça va
dans le bon sens donc il y a aucun
magistrat qui va aussi bah non on va on
va refuser la manne financière mais je
veux juste contextualiser pour que mes
concitoyens est quand même un ordre
d'idée le budget effectivement 9,6
milliards pour 2023 ça représente 1,4%
du budget de l'État un musée de l'État
c'est 384 milliards sous contrôle des
parlementaires ici présent
il faudra beaucoup plus et il faut que
ça s'inscrive effectivement dans le dans
le long terme et puis je rappelle que la
justice en est un programme une mission
pardon mission justice que le budget
divisé en programme notamment trois
programmes métiers ce qui va impacter
vraiment la crise de la justice que vous
avez vu les médias vous à travers la la
fameuse tribune c'est ce qu'on appelle
le programme justice judiciaire et le
problème du SI judiciaire j'ai pris les
chiffres ça sera 3,9 3,4 pardon
milliards d'euros sur ces 3,4 milliards
d'euros il faudra également des falques
ce qu'on appelle les frais de justice
c'est-à-dire des choses qui vont être
engagées pour autre chose que les
tribunaux et les magistrats et les
greffiers donc je contextualise je dis
que c'est un bon début c'est ce que dit
à peu près le corps et que l'argent va
pas forcément au bon endroit c'est ça
alors après je rejoins ce que dit
monsieur le député il va falloir
regarder précisément comment va être
ventilé effectivement la manne
financière qui nous a annoncé alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est de se comparer
évidemment à d'autres pays d'Europe
alors regardez ces chiffres publiés
à la fin de l'année dernière enfin ils
sont basés c'est important sur des
données de l'année 2020 dépense par an
et par habitant pour le la justice
l'Allemagne est loin devant envoyer avec
sa voisine autrichienne autour de 140 €
par an et par habitant l'Espagne la
Belgique autour de
87,88 la moyenne européenne c'est 79 la
France était à
72,53 encore une fois donner de l'année
Erwan alors on en est aujourd'hui et
alors et où est-ce qu'on où est-ce qu'on
sera à la fin en fait ma question c'est
11 milliards en 2027 ça nous placerait
où quoi est-ce qu'on remonte vraiment
dans le classement on remonte mais ces
tableaux ne prennent jamais en compte
une donnée c'est qu'en France on a une
particularité importante c'est qu'on a
aussi la justice administrative et la
justice administrative dans notre pays a
fait un gros gros boulot tout le
contentieux d'urbanisme le contentieux
envers et aussi pris en compte
essentiellement par la justice
administrative elle est pas dans ces
chiffres d'accord et j'aimerais bien
toujours quelqu'un fasse le tableau moi
j'ai essayé de le faire c'est pas simple
ça demande beaucoup de temps
pour qu'on ait rajoute le budget de la
justice rajoute le budget de la justice
administrative qui sont des
fonctionnaires aussi et qui ne sont pas
dans cette ligne là alors maintenant
comment on va faire comment le garde des
sceaux le gouvernement les
parlementaires le Sénat et l'Assemblée
et ben on va avoir un certain nombre de
textes qui seront de l'ordre du
règlementaire et c'est le c'est le garde
des sceaux et la Chancellerie qui va qui
va régler ça et nous on aura quelques
lois de programmation et loi à mettre en
place en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est qu'il faut de l'argent mais il
faut aussi certaines réorganisations et
les annonces du garde des sceaux sur la
réorganisation par exemple plus de
déconcentration des ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui et c'est l'exemple qui
prenait le garde des sceaux et que moi
j'avais eu que j'avais eu aussi en
discutant avec les juridictions chez moi
et le tribunal de de Quimper c'est que
parfois vous avez
un matériel qui dysfonctionne et il
fallait remonter par Paris pour que la
décision soit prise de le changer par
exemple sur la vidéo sur la vidéo pas
surveillance mais vidéo les
visions
conférence bon c'est un exemple concret
ça c'est souvent des sources d'économie
de on serait organise et puis il y a
tout un travail qui va être fait aussi
mais qui sera plus de long terme et qui
je pense donnera sans doute plus de
facilité au
magistrat c'est c'est la
reconndification d'un certain nombre de
codes le code de procédure pénale on va
s'y mettre ça c'est un deuxième temps
mais l'enjeu j'espère que l'enjeu
des moyens financiers il faut des
magistrats sup alors justement
c'est ce qu'il y a dans ce dans ces
projets aussi il y a la question
effectivement du recrutement Agnès
Canada 10000 emplois supplémentaires
d'ici 2027 je reprends les annonces du
du ministre dont 1500 magistrats 1500
greffiers
c'est à la hauteur de l'enjeu là aussi
je repose un peu la même question mais
en détaillant sur la sur le recrutement
est-ce que ce sont les bons recrutements
au bon endroit alors écoutez c'est déjà
mieux que ce qui a été fait des
présentes années avec les fameux
contractuels les sucres rapides selon
les mots du garde des sceaux qui était
venu qui était là pour simplement
répondre à l'urgence pour des stocks
parce que c'est beau et horrible mais
c'est l'ensemble des dossiers qui
restent en attente dans les dans les
tribunaux et donc ces fameux
contractuels ils étaient pas pérennes
ils avaient des statues qui étaient
bancales et ils avaient des missions qui
étaient pas toujours très très bien
définies là l'avantage
c'est que effectivement c'est qu'une
avancée est-ce que ça suffira je suis
pas sûr mais au moins ce sont des postes
pérennes de magistrats et de greffiers
ça c'est une première chose la
difficulté qui va être de les former
suffisamment et en temps suffisant parce
que j'ai informé aussi bien formé et que
le l'école de la magistrature puisse
absorber
ces formations pour l'école des greffes
et qu'il soit opérationnels assez
rapidement parce qu'il y a vraiment une
urgence aujourd'hui à ce qu'il soit dans
les tribunaux Jérôme pose est-ce que ça
permettra aux Français de retrouver en
quelque sorte un accès plus direct au
magistrat quand ils ont besoin non
pourquoi alors 1500 magistrats pour moi
c'est pas une délibération du comité
sauvé mais 500 magistrats c'est ce qui
est dans le programme présidentiel de
Monsieur Macron qui est repris par le
comité sauvé si on avait regardé les
États généraux il y avait pas mal de
professionnels dans le comité des États
généraux et notamment je me base sur ce
que la hiérarchie judiciaire avait un
petit peu estimé à l'époque notamment la
Conférence nationale des des présidents
des tribunaux qui avait dit il nous
manque 2200 juges de 1200 vues sans
compter donc les magistrats du parquet
ok la valeur médiane en Europe puisque
vous avez annoncé les chiffres on est
sur 11 11 procureurs pour 100000
habitants et à peu près 17 juges pour
100 000 habitants avec
on n'y est pas du tout pour qu'on arrive
à la valeur médiane pas la valeur
moyenne la valeur moyenne c'est 17
procureurs pour 5000 habitants et 18
juge pour 100 mille habitants on arrive
simplement il faudrait 5000 magistrats
5000 magistrats c'est le comment dire
c'est le strict minimum s'il est
Français veulent avoir la sensation que
ça va changer et qui vont avoir accès à
leur juge mais on verra mais là il y a
aussi l'idée avancée par le garde des
sceaux de de renforcer les équipes
autour des magistrats donc finalement
leur donner plus de temps pour faire le
métier quand même en cinq ans on va
recruter plus de magistrats dans les 20
dernières années en cinq ans donc
franchement oui mais c'était la question
elle va changer quelque chose pour les
Français
de la même façon que ce que le garde des
sceaux appelle les sucres rapides et qui
sont les fameux contractuels bon je suis
désolé il y avait une levée de bouclier
contre ces postes au départ aujourd'hui
il y a pas beaucoup de présidents de
tribunal qui va vous dire enlever les
mois ils sont contents qu'ils soient là
et on va les ici on va aller on va
pérenniser ces postes là on va les
institutionnaliser on va leur donner un
statut et tout ça va dans le bon sens et
effectivement le magistrat pour qu'il
fonctionne bien il a besoin d'une équipe
et c'est dans les 10 000 recrutements il
y a aussi tous ceux qui feront partie de
l'équipe du magistrat c'est ça les 10 il
y a 1500 magistrats
et 1500 greffiers c'est ça le chiffre
7000 il reste 7000 bah 7000 j'imagine
que c'est tous ces personnes qui font un
travail formidable et qui vont être
institutionnalisés qui seront des aides
juridiques importants le le juge il a
besoin d'une équipe alors on rentre dans
le détail du juge dans ce pays qui est
le juge solitaire qu'on voit dans les
dans les séries non un juge aujourd'hui
s'il veut bien fonctionner il a besoin
d'une équipe en rentrant dans le détail
mais sans être trop trop technique si
vous voulez bien mais effectivement de
qui vous avez besoin autour de vous pour
bien faire votre métier mais le problème
est que ce que je veux faire comprendre
au parlementaire et aux téléspectateurs
c'est qu'on a besoin de juge d'abord
avant d'avoir une équipe il faut des
juges voilà on est quand j'entends on va
recruter 1500 magistrats 1500 greffiers
donc tant mieux mais les 7000 qu'est-ce
que va être les amis pourquoi on appelle
recruté 5000 magistrats ce que demandait
la profession ce que demandait le corps
pourquoi faire le choix et c'est un
choix politique d'aller chercher je vous
interrompre ces métiers là ils vont
peut-être vous décharger d'un certain
nombre de
tâches administratives de voilà qui sont
pas le cœur du métier d'injeux ça peut
peut-être vous simplifier le bois je
suis un petit peu sur la défensive parce
que et c'est si vous me posez la
question peut-être qu'on analysera un
petit peu en prenant du recul sur ce que
ce qui sort de de ces annonces là c'est
que on est parti sur le principe que ce
qui le citoyen demandé c'est d'avoir une
justice plus rapide c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais ce qu'il demandait aussi et ça
personne ne l'entend c'est d'avoir accès
à un juge
le citoyen il attend pas d'avoir accès à
l'équipe du magistrat il veut à l'avoir
accès à son juge et tout le corpus de ce
qui est annoncé mais en avant un espèce
de recul du juge non non
et vous pouvez répondre après
j'entends cette demande de magistrat
mais ce que je pense aujourd'hui c'est
que on a aussi tendance à anticiper sans
avoir vraiment l'évaluation ce qui
importe c'est quand même de connaître la
charge du magistrat et le garde des
sceaux s'est engagé depuis des années à
nous à mener une étude pour évaluer
quelle est la charge réelle de travail
du magistrat vous devez avoir cette
étude à la fin de 2022 on l'a toujours
pas et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
d'abord cette analyse pour savoir où
comment et quels sont les magistrats
dont on a besoin ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose sur l'emploi des
magistrats c'est très bien d'augmenter
le nombre de postes encore faut-il que
trouver les bons candidats au bon pote
je vous rappelle qu'il y a 7% de postes
de greffier qui ne sont pas occupés
aujourd'hui et de poste de magistrats
qui ne sont pas remplis non plus quand
vous étiez au pouvoir ah mais je dis pas
j'en vois pas la responsabilité je dis
simplement que c'est l'addition des
choses et que c'est très bien de créer
des postes mais encore faut-il pouvoir
former et que ces postes soient pourvu
donc il y a une attractivité de la
fonction de magistrac et notre activité
de la fonction de greffier qui passe par
une revalorisation et elle est dans les
propositions qui passent aussi par une
amélioration de la qualité de travail je
pense que ça vient aussi des conditions
d'organisation de l'équipe autour du
magistrat etc
ecoutez je dis pas que ça pas été fait
je dis simplement que il y a eu une
innovation après il faut que
vous me posez une question laquelle je
ne remets pas en question les avancées
qui sont aujourd'hui
proposés par le garde des sceaux j'ai
dit simplement que c'est bien et
attention de pas perdre des bénéfices si
vous écoutez bien ce que je dis en
mettant les choses dans le bon sens
simplement oui mais par exemple
aujourd'hui
former des juges on va en former plus
mais faut savoir aujourd'hui le nm ils
sont dans des algeco donc parce que
parce que pour aller plus vite on a le
l'école voilà
dans le budget il y a aussi un volet
justement sur le Nm pour l'agrandir et
pour avoir des bonnes conditions ensuite
vous parlez de l'avoir accès au juge bon
moi je veux bien on a parlé des moyens
je crois que tout le monde reconnaît ici
qu'il y a des moyens financiers qui sont
conséquents et qui même s'ils sont durs
rattrapage et sont énormes et que c'est
très bien il faut continuer maintenant
vous parliez de le citoyen il va avoir
accès au juge et bah parlons-en et quand
on fait par exemple cette nouveau
système de développer l'amiable en
passant par la césure c'est-à-dire que
c'est le juge qui va dire le droit et en
laissant après aux parties de trouver
les méthodes de de de
compromis pour
que chacun
en réalité paye son dû si je me permets
de parler un peu crûment le juge va dire
le droit aujourd'hui c'était pas c'était
les gens attendent longtemps avant de
voir le juge là ils vont devoir beaucoup
plus vite et ça va mieux fonctionner
parlons de la justice
moi je peux vous développer si vous
voulez avoir un
retour du terrain le mais le retour du
terrain de quelque chose qui est pas
encore mis en place ça va être difficile
justement ça va être difficile
aujourd'hui vous avez des parties sur un
sujet un contentieux de l'immobilier de
logement
le juge la personne va attendre très
longtemps va s'agacer les deux parties
vont ça va aller dans le stock ça va
emboliser les services l'idée c'est
d'aller plus vite et de dire le juge dit
mais c'est vous qui avez raison c'est
vous qui avez tort reste vous vous
avez maintenant un mois pour trouver une
solution sur le règlement de ce conflit
voilà et après dans un mois je vais
aller bien est-ce que ça peut marcher ça
mais pourquoi expliquez-nous pourquoi on
a un contre point technique tout simple
pas trop compliqué non plus on a pas
beaucoup de spécialistes vous vous êtes
spécialiste mais pas forcément noter les
spectateurs ne l'oublions pas à
comprendre c'est le comment dire le
citoyen a trop mais trop de temps à ce
que le jugement sorte et vous dites
c'est pour ça que on va faire une césure
le juge dit le droit ensuite il se
débrouille sur tout ce qui est le
l'indemnisation voilà tout ça c'est
encadré mais alors pourquoi faire ce
choix de là où il y a un juge ne pas en
mettre deux ou trois pour que les choses
sortent plus vite et parce que ça lui je
vais de faire trois trois trois dossiers
en même temps choisir de d'externaliser
moi je vais fournir peut-être parce
qu'on est en train de dire que ça va
déjà être difficile de former 1500
nouveaux juges vu nos capacités de
formation et donc autant former aller
chercher de différents métiers mais
voilà je je j'imagine
l'indemnisation comment vous vous
assurez qu'il soit formé on va faire
appel à des prestataires extérieurs à
des prestations les médiateurs il y aura
des médiateurs d'État mais il y aura
aussi médiateur du privé quand ces
personnes-là vont venir dire quel quelle
part d'indemnisation je donne à a quelle
part d'indemnisation je donne à B ça
sera ensuite soumis à l'homogo
l'homologation du juge si le juge dit
non à la fin on repart dans le repas se
mettre d'accord vous voyez
encore beaucoup à aborder
on entend votre vos arguments je me
tourne vers Mathieu parce que ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la personnalité
on va dire de du garde des sceaux d'Éric
Dupond-Moretti 2 ans et demi après ça
nomination la greffe politique a-t-elle
pris il y a un paradoxe si la politique
c'était le règne de la logique cet homme
là devrait être accueilli en héros
porter en triomphe dans tous les
tribunaux de France rendez-vous compte
le budget a augmenté on en a parlé ici
alors on a bien compris les limites de
l'exercice on a bien compris que les
magistrats et pas prendre leur décision
avec des stylos en or on a bien compris
que c'est un rattrapage mais enfin ça
reste quand même un effort sans
précédent dans l'histoire de notre pays
qui a longtemps alloué de trop faible
moyen on a eu à la justice et c'est
surtout de quoi financer et on vient en
parler notamment l'embauche de 10000
fonctionnaires de plus la construction
de 15000 places de prison dans toute
autre ministère en fait dans toute autre
administration quand même le ministre
est devenu un jean d'idole mais voilà
Eric Dupont-Moretti reste pour beaucoup
dans son dans son administration auprès
des magistrats une bête noire sinon un
ennemi et alors comment ça s'explique
d'abord une raison qui tient son passé
c'était un avocat pas un magistrat et
akitor c'était son surnom il y a
toujours fait voilà pas toujours fait
dans la dentelle lui au prix de gants à
l'égard de des juges lorsqu'il écumait
les prétoirs son opinion sur la justice
telle qu'elle était rendue dans notre
pays a souvent fait les gros titres des
journaux au point que lorsqu'il a été
nommé son passé par les déjà pour lui et
que beaucoup de magistrats l'attendaient
au tournant et puis ensuite il y a sa
volonté politique de transformation en
profondeur de l'appareil judiciaire
français qui a heurté aussi les
magistrats je donne des exemples les
audiences filmées là on vient de parler
de la médiation civile on parlera
peut-être de la simplification du code
de procédure pénale c'est une révision
en profondeur une en profondeur que veut
porter le garde des sceaux et qui heurte
bien entendu des habitudes parfois des
bonnes choses des mauvaises choses mais
enfin voilà qui qui bousculent la
seconde raison il y a une erreur un peu
originelle oui qui tient une erreur
qu'il a commise à son arrivée qui est de
ne pas s'être immédiatement déporté des
affaires qui ayant pu le concerné de
près ou de loin alors avec
Dupont-Moretti explique aujourd'hui
qu'il avait d'autres chats fouetter
l'été où il a été nommé qui constitue
son cabinet qu'il s'est déporté dans les
faits quelques mois plus tard
notamment à au profit de Matignon occupé
alors par Jean Castex il n'empêche cette
faute originelle elle a nourrit le
soupçon de mélange des genres pour le
garde des sceaux et le ressentiment et
la colère de ceux qui œuvrent pour le
voir renvoyé pour briser les gars
d'intérêt devant la Cour de Justice de
la République et puis enfin quelque
chose qui tient à l'homme à mon avis à
son style à sa personnalité d'ours mal
léché capable de coup de sang comme de
coup de boule rhétorique à l'Assemblée
ou ailleurs hâbleur rancunier homme de
réseau les qualificatifs fusent quand
vous interrogez ces détracteurs c'est
vrai qu'il fait pas toujours dans la
dentelle
Eric Dupond-Moretti il met pas toujours
l'effort on a vu par exemple que le fait
que les syndicats ne lui parlent pas
pendant autant de temps depuis son
arrivée pour un ministre c'est quand
même très compliqué quand vous ne pouvez
pas discuter ou recevoir les syndicats
quoi que vous en pensez il a pas su
alors si on se la mettre de la poche au
moins renouer une forme de dialogue
est-ce que l'annonce là de ce plan peut
changer la donne alors c'est ce que ces
amis espèrent et ils ont peut-être
quelques raisons d'espérer alors bien
sûr il reste beaucoup de grief bien sûr
il y a beaucoup de choses et bien sûr
l'essentiel c'est de mettre en oeuvre
son plan d'action pour la justice et ça
va être compliqué à la fois sur la forme
et sur le fond on comprend parce qu'il y
a des vrais des accords mais mais il
faut reconnaître que même ceux qui lui
étaient le plus opposé ont été obligés
de reconnaître l'ampleur de l'effort
budgétaire à l'image de l'Union
Syndicale des Magistrats qui est
majoritaires dans la profession qui
s'est dit satisfaite sur l'aspect
budgétaire alors il reste encore des
choses à faire mais quand même c'est
peut-être le début d'un processus
respect de la part de ce syndicat qui
avait accueilli la nomination d'Éric
Dupont-Moretti comme une déclaration de
guerre est-ce que les magistrats c'est
très difficile de d'amalgamer mais il y
avait un a priori des favorables par
rapport à ce ministre à son histoire à
son surnom akitateur assez proposé alors
c'est vrai qu'il a eu des propos peu
amen sur sur les magistrats mais je
pense que les magistrats étaient en
capacité de comment dire de surmonter a
priori là de dépasser ça et de voir
quelle était la vision pour la justice
de de Eric Dupont-Moretti moi c'est pas
la personnalité de me dérange absolument
pas moi ce qui me ce qui me comment dire
ce qui me pose question et ce qui
m'inquiète au final c'est la direction
qu'il donne et Monsieur le Député va
sûrement renchérir sur sur ce que je
vais dire mais encore une fois
l'inquiétude qui est celle de pas mal de
magistrats c'est quelle est la place du
juge au final
le règlement amiable c'est effectivement
on dit on vient aider le juge mais c'est
pas c'est pas assister le juge c'est
quelque part le supplay on va parler du
pénal tout à l'heure
dans le plan il y a quelque chose par
exemple qui j'ai pris un exemple qui va
parler à tout le monde il décide dans
ses 60 annonces
de faire en sorte que toutes les
contraventions c'est à dire les les ne
pas respecter un feu rouge ou comment
dire français une ligne continue des
petites violences qui passaient devant
le tribunal de police toutes les
contraventions vont faire l'objet d'un
procès-verbal électronique qui donnera
lieu à une amende forfaitaire c'est à
dire qu'on court tourne le juge de
police qui est un juge de paix qui a un
juge de proximité le règlement amiable
je voulais déjà dit on contourne le juge
d'instruction et on va venir sur la
politique carcérale et le juge
d'application des peines devient un juge
de l'incident gestionnaire simplement du
flux carcéral donc vous dites finalement
le le pouvoir du juge se réduit avec
c'est ce que c'est le principal qui est
important moi je peux pas laisser à
partir du moment où on va avoir une
justice qui fonctionne mieux avec des
juges qui ont plus de moyens le pouvoir
du juge va se renforcer dans ce pays
voilà mais aujourd'hui je suis désolé je
suis désolé aujourd'hui pour le coup le
juge n'a pas de pouvoir dans ce pays
aujourd'hui il est mal il est mal aimé
parce qu'il est trop lent mais je suis
désolé moi c'est les ressentis que j'ai
et je suis sur le terrain et aujourd'hui
on parlait du du garde des sceaux le
garde des sceaux il va dans beaucoup de
juridictions en ce moment et il y a une
différence entre effectivement peut-être
les syndicats et les leaders syndicats
parisiens et la réalité sur le terrain
il est accueilli aujourd'hui et il suce
son plan suscite l'espoir donc il faut
il faut continuer et en plus on a des
moyens énormes on a des réorganisations
qui vont dans le bon sens c'est pas
parce que le des magistrats ont un
contentieux avec un homme qui qui on
peut pas avoir des des a priori comme ça
voilà moi j'avais pour rien vous cacher
j'ai travaillé avec Dupont-Moretti j'ai
été le premier rapporteur d'un texte du
premier texte qu'il a porté j'avais pas
je le connaissais pas j'avais pas un a
priori favorable défavorable ce que j'ai
rencontré c'est quelqu'un qui écoute qui
bosse et qui a qu'une idée c'est la
réussite de la main parce que le temps
file un mot là-dessus est-ce que
l'indépendance parce que c'est ce que
vous nous dites pas finalement
par vos par vos votre ressenti est-ce
que la dépense du juge elle est assez
protégée par cette réforme
bah écoutez elle doit être garantie mais
le juge fait partie aussi de la société
et c'est aussi une institution qui doit
participer à redonner confiance dans les
institutions je rappelle quand même et
ce que disait monsieur le député il y a
53 % des Français qui n'ont pas
confiance dans la justice aujourd'hui
donc l'indépendance du juge elle est
nécessaire mais elle doit pas être ça ne
doit pas conduire à être à ce que le
juge soit en dehors de la société et une
des volontés aussi c'est de redonner au
juge du lien avec la société dans
laquelle il évolue l'indépendance du
juge et du magistrat c'est effectivement
un point cardinal moi je pense que
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
particulièrement remise en question le
sujet vraiment c'est que le juge est
c'est pouvoir recentrer sur sa fonction
de magistrat rendre la justice et moi je
pense que c'est utile que pour cela il
soit aidé et accompagné qui est une
vraie répartition des rôles pour
redonner du temps au magistrat pour
faire ce qui est le rôle premier d'un
magistrat c'est rendre la et donc d'où
cette importance de réorganisation de la
justice allez on va parler maintenant de
de la surpopulation carcérale propose à
Quentin calmer de nous rejoindre bonsoir
Quentin bien sûr le nombre de détenus en
France à atteint un record absolu l'an
dernier en 2022 voilà le nombre de
détenus en France est à son plus haut
historique et ce depuis le mois de
novembre 2022 on compte en France
87721 personnes écrouées au 1er décembre
ce sont les chiffres officiels fournis
par un ministère 72 836 000 d'entre
elles sont détenus les autres disposent
d'aménagement de peine un chiffre à
comparer vous le voyez sur cet écran au
nombre de places opérationnelles 60 698
ça donne un taux de suroccupation de
120% et même de 142% en moyenne dans les
81 maison d'arrêt là où il y a les
personnes en détention provisoire Thomas
comment évolue ce taux au cours des
dernières décennies et bien nous
disposons des statistiques depuis 2005
grâce au ministère de la justice la
courbe en rouge et celle du nombre de
détenus en France on voit le chiffre
d'ailleurs qui chute au moment de la
crise 2020 de la crise covid et on voit
en bleu le nombre de places disponibles
donc on voit en 2020 en fait c'est le
seul moment où le chiffre du nombre de
détenus passent sous la barre du nom de
Place disponibles ce que l'on retient
c'est que le nombre de prisonniers en
France est en constante augmentation
depuis le début des années 2000 tout
comme le nombre de places de prison
autour de 50000 en 2005 pour attendre
60700 fin 2022 avec une forte
augmentation autour de 2010 sous le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy et puis
on l'a évoqué le gouvernement travaille
à la construction de 15000 places de
prison en plus d'ici 2000 par rapport à
2017 voilà la promesse d'Emmanuel Macron
date effectivement de 2017 elle était
initialement prévue pour aboutir en 2022
l'objectif l'objectif sera en fait sans
doute atteint à la fin du deuxième
quinquennat le gain des Sceaux est très
attendu sur le sujet de la surpopulation
carcérale mais pour l'instant il n'a pas
repris les position des états généraux
de la justice après les états généraux
de la justice effectivement
souvenez-vous le comité des États
généraux avait remis un rapport
Jean-Marc Sauvé avait fait des
propositions c'était lui vous le voyez à
l'image qui présidait ce comité des
états généraux de la justice il avait
dit et qu'il fallait davantage de
volontarisme en matière de réinsertion
ou encore l'idée de mettre en place je
cite un dispositif de régulation de la
population carcérale alors c'est là
dessus que il y a de nombreux regrets
qui ont été exprimés par les membres du
comité notamment François Molins le
procureur général il a dit sa déception
sur cette partie des annonces c'était
sur RTL le 10 janvier dernier en
l'écoute
on aurait pu aller plus loin sur le fond
des mesures c'est pareil pour la
pénitentiaire ou les réflexions du
rapport sauvé c'était de redonner du
sens à la peine au service d'une
réinsertion qui était effective et qui
se traduisait par un suivi beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup plus
étroit des probationnaires et lutter
contre la surpopulation pénitentiaire à
travers effectivement des mécanismes de
régulation on n'a pas ça effectivement
et on a l'opposé de ce qu'on avait dit
une quelque chose qui finalement revient
à vouloir résoudre le problème de la
surpopulation pénitentiaire uniquement
avec la construction de nouvelle peine
de prison c'est pas encore une fois ce
qu'avait dit le rapport sauvé un dernier
mot puisque le comité de des agents de
la Justice a aussi dit qu'il fallait
lutter contre cette idée reçue selon
laquelle les magistrats sont laxistes
pourquoi parce qu'on observe ces
dernières années une aggravation du
quantum moyen des peines prononcées par
exemple les peines prononcées dans la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
ont fait passer certaines peines d'un
six mois vers des peines de 6 à 12 mois
c'est aussi ce qui explique
l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
écrouées en France Merci Quentin calmé
pour pour tous ces détails un Escal
est-ce que vous partagez les les regrets
du procureur général François Molins je
vais le citer de nouveau y rappelait
cette ambition
du rapport sauvé redonner du sens à la
peine pour améliorer la réinsertion en
sortie de prison oui effectivement alors
on peut pas se satisfaire de cette
surpopulation carcérale qui est
d'ailleurs diverses en fonction des
établissements et en fonction des
territoires d'une part d'autre part moi
je crois beaucoup effectivement à la
réinsertion et au suivi de des peines
des détenus on voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'on a peu et pas assez non plus de
conseiller en probation qui suivent les
détenus ils ont entre guillemets suivent
à peu près 80 détenus en moyenne on voit
qu'au Royaume-Uni alors il y a peut-être
un milieu à trouver entre les deux mais
au Royaume-Uni c'est un conseiller pour
10 détenus et je pense qu'il y a
vraiment besoin de mettre des moyens
aussi sur ce suivi des peines pour
favoriser la ré et travailler aussi
mieux avec d'autres acteurs du
territoire et mieux faire accepter la
peine je pense aussi que une des
difficultés de la prison c'est que on
enferme dans des établissements uniques
quel que soit le type de peine et je
pense qu'il y a une réflexion aussi à
mener sur des établissements spécifiques
notamment pour les courtes peines parce
qu'on sait que emprisonné
des détenus de courte peine avec des
longues peines ça peut avoir des effets
contre-productifs
le côté comptable c'est un peu la
réponse la plus simple
15000 places supplémentaires c'est pas
c'est
utile et nécessaire parce que c'est pas
15000 c'est 15000 places c'est des
rénovations c'est aussi donner des
conditions dignes pour les personnes qui
sont en prison aujourd'hui nous on a la
chance quand on est parlementaire enfin
je sais pas si c'est une chance de
pouvoir aller dans les prisons comme ça
comme on veut pour contrôler je peux
vous dire c'est terrible et donc il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on ait une des actions
politiques fortes sur le sujet 15000
places supplémentaires ça répond à ça
déjà ça répond à des meilleures
conditions mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
retombe dans le tout tout prison
puisqu'on est à côté de ça on a fait
beaucoup de choses pour la mise en place
des peines alternatives et il faut
continuer ensuite moi je suis très
sensible à cette idée d'avoir des
typologies de de prison c'est à dire que
suivant les les cas suivant les peines
suivant le moment de la de
l'emprisonnement aussi parce que parfois
les prix les tenlongues la fin de la
peine n'est pas la même que le début il
faut qu'on ait des il faut qu'on ait
cette typologie différente en tout cas
en tout cas en tout état de choses
aujourd'hui on peut pas se satisfaire de
la situation telle qu'elle est c'est
terrible et et les prisons françaises ne
sont vraiment pas la gloire de notre
République et on ne peut pas laisser
faire ça Jérôme posa sur les
alternatives à l'incarcération
ce qui est proposé là c'est l'une des
mesures proposées par par Eric
Dupond-Moretti est-ce que vous pensez
que ça ça va dans le bon sens
vous allez me trouver redondant non mais
là encore donc je rejoins ce que ce qu'a
dit madame la sénatrice et je rejoins
peut-être aussi ce qu'a dit Monsieur le
Député c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un effort
sur la probation en France on a doublé
les effectifs du service pénitentiaire
d'insertion des progressions les
éducateurs qui accompagnent les sortants
de prison ou les détenus en prison donc
pour faire en sorte que la réinsertion
il faut un éducateur à côté d'un d'un
d'une personne à réinsérer ceci dit
madame la sénatrice a rappelé les
chiffres actuellement là je suis en
voyage je suis de nouveau juste
d'application des peines ça faisait 10
ans que j'avais quitté cette fonction je
reviens et ce que je vois c'est que
effectivement on a toujours un
conseiller pour en maison d'arrêt sans
personne et à l'extérieur on a un
conseiller pour 85 90 personnes
la comment dire l'objectif de la
pénitentiaire c'est 1 pour 60 d'accord
on en est loin mais au-dessus de tout ça
il y a le juge d'application des peines
l'association professionnelle des juges
d'application des peines la redit elle a
fait un rapport très circonstancié
qu'elle a qu'elle a remis d'ailleurs je
crois au parlementaire il faut doubler
le nombre de juge d'applications des
peines actuellement là je peux vous le
dire je suis en stage de changement de
fonction donc je discute avec tous les
collègues un juge d'application des
peines suit 1000 à 1200 personnes il a
1200 personnes sous son contrôle à
l'extérieur d'accord comment voulez-vous
qu'on y arrive alors il y a des choses
qui ont été faites notamment la
libération sous contrainte et notamment
ce dernier ersat ce qu'on appelle la
libération sous contrainte de droit
c'est-à-dire où on fait sortir à trois
mois de sa fin de peine le détenu et
pour qu'ils puissent se réinsérer mais
on n'a pas les effectifs pour ça
il faut comment dire le slip ne peut pas
accompagner individuellement donc ils
font des plateformes collectives mais
qui ne vont pas marcher les types qui
vont sortir ils vont pas penser à aller
sur une plateforme collective et à
écouter un message sur
les moyens d'un suivi véritable ah non
non on est très loin on est très loin
encore mais parce qu'il manque encore
une fois du juge et il manque du liant
entre le juge et le Conseil d'insertion
moi j'entends et la réinsertion
l'accompagnement éviter les sorties
sèches chez primordial la libération
sous contrainte ça va dans ce sens ça
prend effet au 1er janvier et vous la
saluez
pas vous la saluez pas parce que je vais
marcher c'est un aménagement de peine
décidé en trois mois vous ne pouvez pas
comment dire fonder les conditions d'une
bonne réinsertion exactement et donc
c'est pour ça aussi la régulation c'est
à dire on a trop de gens en prison on
les fait sortir trois mois avant comme
ça on règle et on peut en faire rentrer
d'autres c'est pas nous en tout cas
c'est certainement pas l'idée d'ailleurs
moi je suis me pose à cette idée d'avoir
un humérus cl plus dans les prisons
parce que ça serait un chèque en blanc
pour pour certains bandits de savoir il
y a plus de place en prison je peux y
aller là non soyons sérieux par contre
le garde des sceaux et c'est une volonté
aussi de la majorité c'est de développer
massivement le travail en prison c'est à
dire que le travail en prison qui permet
l'insertion qui permet l'accompagnement
et qui permet aussi de donner et on l'a
fait on a créé un statut du prisonnier
aujourd'hui les prises jusqu'à
maintenant les prisonniers avaient un
statut qui était un peu je veux dire un
peu lamentable là ils ont un statut ils
ont des des choses qui leur permettent
de travailler un peu plus sereinement il
faut aller dans ce sens là parce que
l'inactivité en prison c'est terrible
alors il y a le travail il y a le suivi
il y a les bon voilà j'entends ça je
vais redonner la parole à on vous a
beaucoup entendu un ordinaire sur cette
question du travail en prison oui ça ça
marche pas pour l'instant c'est vraiment
un chantier majeur c'est un chantier
important et ça ne marche pas on l'a
voté j'étais rapporteur dans la loi
confiance dans la justice en redonnant
des droits détenu effectivement et en
lui donnant un vrai statut de
travailleurs en prison alors avec les
particularités évidemment de
l'incarcération et les contraintes qui
pèsent sur eux aujourd'hui forcer de
constater quand même que il y a peu
d'entreprises qui donnent du travail au
détenues incarcérées parce que c'est
très contraignant et que c'est
économiquement pour le moment pas
extrêmement viable donc c'est une bonne
idée mais qui fonctionne pas et en plus
il y a un vrai sujet aussi de place dans
les prisons pour mettre en place ces
ateliers et développer des filières de
travail qui peuvent permettre aux
détenus de d'avoir une continuité entre
ce qui ne vit en prison et ce qui
pourrait vivre à l'extérieur beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était passionnant j'ai
emposage j'appelle ce manifeste pour une
justice humaine et indépendante coécrit
avec Marie bougnou et Laurent Sebag
publié aux éditions Enrique B voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission votre
prochain rendez-vous sur notre antenne
pour du politique Philippe Martinez
secrétaire général de la CGT qui demain
dans la matinale de Public Sénat
malheureusement on sera pas là en direct
demain puisqu'il y a une grève d'une
partie du personnel j'aurais bien aimé
commenté cette journée d'action et de
manifestations c'est la vie on s'adapte
belle soirée